-Sarah, it is your turn.
Why don't you pull the mic?
Let's see what you get.
-Wah!
-Don't be nervous.
-You got this.
-Jimmy!
-It's fine. It's fine.
-It's gonna be great.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Wheel of Musical Impressions!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Wheel of Musical
Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of Musical
-Sarah, for this one,
you're gonna get an artist
and then you have to sing
a song while doing
an impression of them.
What song will it be?
♪♪
-"Genie"...
-No, no.
-Ha!
-Oh, my God!
You got this.
This is -- This is easy.
-They're my two favorites!
I love them!
-"Genie in a Bottle,"
but sung by Avril Lavigne.
-Okay.
-Ah. Yeah.
-Okay. Good. Yeah.
-Yes and, girl! Yes and!
-Can we get Sarah, like,
an emo type of groove?
-Here we go. Emo.
Drums!
♪♪
-♪ I feel like
I've been locked up tight ♪
♪ For a century
of lonely nights ♪
♪ Waiting for someone
to release me ♪
♪ You're lickin' your lips
and blowing kisses my way ♪
♪ But that don't mean
I'm gonna give it away ♪
♪ Baby, baby, baby, yeah ♪
-Whoa. Sing it!
Sing it, Sarah!
-♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ My body's sayin' let's go ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ But my heart is sayin' no ♪
♪ If you wanna be with me ♪
♪ Baby, there's a price to pay ♪
♪ I'm a genie in a bottle ♪
♪ You gotta rub me
the right way ♪
♪ If you wanna be with me ♪
♪ I can make your wish
come true ♪
♪ You gotta make
a big impression ♪
♪ Gotta like what you do ♪
♪ I'm a genie in a bottle,
baby ♪
♪ Gotta rub me the right way,
honey ♪
♪ I'm a genie in a bottle,
baby ♪
♪ Come, come, come on
and let me out ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright! Yeah!
-Wow!
-Yeah!
-Avril!
-Throwing the mic!
And then picking it up nicely.
-Yes!
-Alright. [ Laughs ]
-It's expensive equipment.
-Wow!
-Oh!
-You got some pipes.
-Oh, thanks.
-And you got
a standing ovation.
-Oh, my God!
-Not too shabby!
Alright.
-That was fabulous!
-Oh, my goodness.
That was great.
-That was fabulous.